the crack in charge the united
opposition
is widening there are no more
anti-government demonstrations on the
streets
and anti-military rhetoric has been
toned down
an opposition candidate in the last
presidential election has been appointed
as transitional prime minister and is
currently selling the idea of dialogue
and unity to others
who oppose the military takeover
we need to come together for the
nation's interest everyone has a role to
play for the peace of the country
we need to do that to restore democracy
where from now on
power will come from the ballot box
it's a call that's resonated with some
opposition leaders
processes we almost agree with the
process
what is more important to chadians is
national reconciliation
at the moment i can say we are united
and agreed on a peaceful transition
in the organization of a national
dialogue conference
two key opposition leaders are now in
the cabinet that's also made up
of the late president idris devis
ministers and loyalists
a move described by analysts as
significant
the parliament which are suspended along
with the constitution is back in
business
an indication that the military rulers
are desperate to win as many civilians
as they can
despite the progress met politically the
situation in charge remains volatile
in the north of the country rebels
remain a significant threat so to the
armed group boko haram
the military leadership here hopes that
the appointment of a respected former
foreign minister
to head national dialogue will persuade
some rebels to join in
the african union has strongly condemned
the military's crackdown on protesters
that resulted in a number of deaths it's
now urging caution
as events unfold
we shouldn't rush we are gathering data
that will allow the council to take the
best decision
we have to wait the pros and cons to
decide on whether
to ban or suspend chad is easy but will
that help or harm the country
that is facing the most difficult period
chad's allies including former colonial
power france fear that if the country
descends into chaos
the entire lake chart and sale regions
will see a rise in attacks by armed
groups
that they say is why they supported the
military takeover
for now the country's military leaders
may have bought themselves some time
but analysts say how they utilize that
time and organize proper elections
within 18 months
will be critical ahmed idris al jazeera
gemini